Billing errors almost invariably are to
our disadvantage.
It's so stunning.
One feels so blessed.
One feels so Leprechaun pod of Goldie
defines a billing error in our favor
that the temptation to take advantage of
it.
It's pretty potent but don't yield to
Here's the essential point.
It's not right to profit from someone
else's innocent error and in your own
life.
If you drop your wallet on the street,
you expect people to return it with the
cash in it.
Someone's innocent error is not meant to
be a profit making opportunity that we
have a kind of civic duty to play our
part,
to return the lost property,
to point out when the door to the bank
has been left ajar,
not to simply exploited.
I wouldn't want to live in that kind of
world.
So in this case,
you can't exploit an innocent air.
Even Time Warner's,
even though you may have harsh feelings
about a person or an entity,
you don't sacrifice your moral values
when you're dealing with him that his
good conduct doesn't just flow to
people.
You regard as good people.
You have a set of ethical principles
that you apply to all people in all
circumstances.
So in this case,
it means Time Warner has made an
innocent error by leaving you with the
de Luxe cable package,
even though you're paying for what I
believe they,
regardless of the cheapskate package,
I think that's how it's designated on my
bill.
You have to let them know now that the
second question becomes,
well,
how hard do you have to try to let them
know and you certainly don't have to
make it your life's work to inform
someone when they've made this kind of
error.
So one phone call.
Yes,
absolutely.
Two phone calls.
Yeah,
I'd say so.
That meets my standard.
After that,
I would send them a letter as much to
protect yourself.
Should you get receive a bill two years
from now for 24 months of the Lux cable
service.
But once you've made a good faith,
reasonable efforts,
and I realized these are ambiguous terms
to inform them about their air,
then they're on their own.
You do not have to make it your life's
work to correct time warner sloppiness.
The other aspect of this is these
exchanges,
these moral exchanges have to be
symmetrical.
That if you would want someone to tell
you that they have overcharged you,
then you have to tell them that they've
undercharged you.
Ethics must have parody.
Ethics must have symmetry for an ethical
proposition to be compelling.
It must seem fair no matter which seat
you're in.